ragazzi siamo al penultimo episodio di
cia cell manca ancora e poi l'ultimo che
uscirà la prossima volta volevo dirvi
che durante il video una certa cambio
maglia non perché sono scemo ma perché
ho registrato il video questo in due
momenti diversi e quindi non
spaventatevi non sono un mago dove vi
piace a buona visione
non ce la fai a fare una roba che sia
una roba normale prende la ciliegia
mangiarlo cosa che non ti si addicono 6
bloccato lì dentro
[Musica]
occhio liberato adesso si gentile devi
colonizzare la razza che l'onda quindi
posso prendere la mia ciliegia mentre
colonizzi pamela prendere dai tetti
costa torta di compleanno
[Musica]
chi adora sei bellissima sono giuro
vabbè musichetta sic luke non ne sbaglia
una
capisco ha intenzione di polverizzare
qualsiasi cosa io ti offro addio anche
la televisione la televisione andini
lobotomizza tutti è anche gli alieni
[Musica]
esatto bravo bravo bravo
eccolo
così se ne fai danni a ciliegia spiega
[Musica]
neanche la tv quindi a fare l'incazzato
che lo sto vedendo dio mio
perfetto molto pisi di quanto pensassi
maniere forti lega ce l'hai fatta
la ciliegia zio storia prima che arrivi
cosino rosa ecco poi alieni dovete
proprio scegliere oggi come giorno per
colonizzare ragazzi pa stiamo difendendo
veramente
ma veramente nel peggio trash rigore per
chi sei sicuro che sia tuo amico questo
ecco infatti avevo sto dubbio fra hai
voglia in qualche modo di randellare lo
coltello va bene ok è degenerata
velocemente la situazione mi sa che sei
peggiorando così zio fidati va bene
raga non dite niente poi la faccia
felice ma non ha il naso cosa annusi è
allergico ai fiori era allergico chi è
va bene questo caso chance ci ho provato
allora alla sveglia la freccia o le sto
provando tutte lega una sarà giusta
palla di carta
la casa di carta la bomba
genio maledizione o è così se non ci sei
tu a farmi guarda aiutarmi un casino
importante arrivarci prima tu zio
arrivarci prima tu eh va beh
amy era pronta che mira brutta cosa la
cerbottana obiettivo cosa devo fare
arrivò già capito solo farlo spar
all'indietro ma li volevo fare proprio
questo io se accade qualcosa d'altro
tipo della madonna va bene
prova a vedere se cade ancora
qualcos'altro macigno per cortesia va
bene anche una nuvola sì però frate non
è che puoi far così tutta la vita te lo
dico a fare il cambio schermo
[Musica]
prova speranze di sparo cuociono
all'altra parte
no però è caduto un mappamondo che
ovviamente dobbiamo continuare così per
tanto qualcosa di gigante grazie
ok va bene
la donna come benissimo mi piace questo
gioco perché c'è meritocrazia
niente arrivato questo sta arrivando è
l'aver sicuramente non posso toccato
abbiategrasso sto tizio che cosa cosa ma
c'e la mula luna porca vacca svetta
bikes ci mette un'ora ad arrivare
proiettile e si sposta pure ma porca eva
maira basta li prego sibello sto colpo
preso in pieno il cav h scusa ho
sbagliato mira la luna un problema
questo è un problema è esattamente
questo è un problema
se va bene va bene
decisamente sbagliato il colpo ma va
bene ciao frate ci vediamo vediamo
no no non rompere le palle ci ho messo
per mangia a gesù mangia mangia la
maledettissima ciliegia
no niente aiutare fu per te lo giuro non
te la recupero più mai più
te lo giuro tocca la adesso si trasforma
in satana però vabbè tocca un'altra
volta abbiamo quanto arriva dal quanto
ci metterà arrivare il demonio
ah beh mi aspettavo un demonio un po più
grosso sinceramente molto più grosso di
una casta che ha con braccio e ride va
bene si puoi continuare a non toccarla
mi dà fastidio come si sta divertendo
questo frate ce ne sono tre adesso è la
madonna mi sa che non ti conviene
tantissimo ora a fare il pirla esatto
più scelti
se quanto ad ora sto gioco da 1 a mille
ancora che ride capisco importante che
si divertano il paese ciao fratello io
non te la prendo quello tra puoi tenere
non se la merita però non ti incazzare
turista di ogni salsa li sta lì l'ho
visto io esatto eccolo c'era un buco lì
sopra ma l'ho visto mai
sì faccio io verona certo non avevo
dubbi lancia questo così no stavo
scherzando
[Musica]
facciamo che parliamo con sto tizio qua
ciao zio a lanciano si si si spera si si
si becca decisi ma lo ripeto in altra
volta così è più chiaro dove esattamente
ti infili sulle cose si è coperto premio
che l'altro una volta che sta lì sopra
schiacciano finisce sulla non era
esattamente quello che volevo fare prove
per questo devo mettere qua giusto che
era questo lo metto cui gli madonna che
bordello schiaccia o quello domani
questo lo riprendi aspetta che devo
capire devo ragionare forte adesso gli
spettano
cosa terra mi metto qua schiaccia
ale
o mio dio che ansia di vivere cosa è
successo qua ci ho messo due ora fosse
roba va bene che cosa che ok
pertanto non mi faccio domande su sto
gioco impossibile perché vicino brutti e
il pulcino più brutto che abbia mai
visto
ma posso decidere cosa fare bla bla
esattamente quello che avrei detto io mi
sa che non gliene frega niente
questo dalla madonna ha fatto tutto
quanto forte ora niente facciamo
un'altra roba facciamo il colletto
[Musica]
grosso vedendo il solletico questo
solletico
ma non è il solletico mi sembrava il
mi sa che in questo modo non risolviamo
niente raga adesso spera aprendo la cd
sacd ager non è esattamente quella prova
beh è riuscito madonna uno più brutto
nell'altro dolega occhio non mi piace il
ticchettio mi sa che esplode da un
momento all'altro non sbaglia quindi
ragazzi i prossimi episodi 17 sarà
l'ultimo purtroppo perché in realtà
questo gioco mi sta piacendo un sacco
però anche le cose belle finiscono
tranne io con ragazzi sia video è
piaciuto lasciate momento mi piace anche
al ritorno mi vedo tra descrizione si
schiera viene ci vediamo a un prossimo
video o sbagliato tutte le gesture e
dell'altro mar chi se ne frega tanto chi
ci arriva fino a questo punto dei video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]